dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA here have
you ever wondered how your voice or your
guitar would sound in the middle of a
space station a realistic simulation of
sounds within virtual environments
dramatically improves the immersion of
the user in computer games and virtual
reality applications to be able to
simulate these effects we need to
compute the interaction between sound
waves and the geometry and materials
within the scene if you remember we also
had quite a few episodes about light
simulations where we simulated the
interaction of light rays or waves and
the scene we have at hand sounds quite
similar right well kind of and the great
thing is that we can reuse quite a bit
of this knowledge in some of the
equations for light transport for sound
this technique we call path tracing and
it is one of the many well known
techniques used for sound simulation we
can use path tracing to simulate the
path of many waves to obtain an impulse
response which is a simple mathematical
function that describes the
reverberation that we hear if we shoot a
gun in a given scene such as a space
station or a church after we obtain
these impulse responses we can use an
operation called the convolution with
our input signal like our voice to get a
really convincing result we have talked
about this in more detail in earlier
episodes as put a link for them in the
video description box it is important to
note that the impulse response depends
on the scene and where we the listeners
are exactly in the scene
in pretty much every concert ever we
find that sound reverberations are quite
different in the middle of the arena
versus standing at the back one of the
main contributions of this work is that
it exploits temporal coherence this
means that even though the impulse
response is different if we stand at
different places but these locations
don't change arbitrarily and we can
reuse a lot of information from the
previous few impulse responses that we
worked so hard to compute this way we
can get away with tracing much fewer
rays
and still get high-quality results in
the best cases the algorithm executes
five times as quickly as previous
techniques and the memory requirements
are significantly more favorable the
paper also contains a user study
limitations include a bit overly smooth
audio signals and some fidelity loss in
the lower frequency domains some of
these scenes in the footage showcase up
to 24 distinct sound sources and all of
them are simulated against the geometry
and the materials found in the scene so
let's listen together and delight in
these magnificent results
this small room has a short
reverberation time
notice how the reverb quality changes as
a listener exits into a large
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time